lindsey graham senator lindsey graham
who's been uh you know in the senate
forever basically he's run for president
a couple of times he sometimes kind of
gets it as a conservative as a
republican and then sometimes doesn't
get it well he's back to the doesn't get
it part uh as you know uh supreme court
justice stephen breyer is stepping down
we covered that last week and joe biden
has said that he's going to have a black
woman replace her because of course
that's what we care about most here in
the united states here's joe himself the
person i will nominate will be someone
with extraordinary qualifications
character experience and integrity
and that person will be the first black
woman ever nominated to united states
supreme court
it's long overdue in my view
so joe wants a black woman replacing
stephen breyer who happens to be a white
man now i don't believe that a supreme
court seat is owned by any one person i
certainly don't believe it's owned by
anyone's skin color or gender
but ironically saying that you're going
to give a job to someone based on the
color of their skin and by their gender
is actually against the civil rights act
of 1963 63 or 64. i always get that
civil rights act is it 63 or 64. give me
a number on that um
so already we're doing something very
bad here now how do i link this to
lindsey graham well you'd think that
every sane conservative or or just sort
of every sane freedom-loving person
would be against this idea that we would
be injecting race into who we hire and
to who gets confirmed as a supreme court
justice the civil rights act 1964. i
will lock that in the brain going
forward but lindsey graham no he's
completely fine with biden's idea here
the idea that we're going to have just a
black woman be the next president reagan
said running for office that he wanted
to put the first female on the court
whether you like it or not joe biden
said i'm going to pick an
african-american woman to serve on the
supreme court i believe there are plenty
of qualified african-american women
conservative and liberal that could go
onto the court so i don't concede i
don't see michelle childs as an act of
affirmative action i do see putting a
black woman on the court making the
court more like america in the history
of our country
we've only had uh five women serve and
two african-american men
man sorry lindsey graham you're exactly
the type of politician that we don't
need anymore you really are we don't
need that pandering drivel nobody is
saying that there aren't
thousands
thousands literally probably hundreds of
thousands of qualified black women to
sit on the supreme court great legal
minds etc etc nobody's saying that
everyone knows that that is
but as a
marker as the original starting point
that here is the pool that i will select
from we have a giant pool but my pool
will just be black women it's not that
you're not going to pick the best person
because the back the best person might
be a black woman but first it's against
the law it's against the law to hire
based on skin color and gender that's
number one a law by the way that had a
little something to do with the supreme
court in the first place but also this
pandering drivel that's why you're
becoming irrelevant lindsey graham this
pandering drivel that it will be a black
woman well why not a native american
woman why not an indian woman i mean
indian from india woman why not an asian
woman are there any chinese american
supreme court justices korean supreme
court justices but no why do we keep
going to that group of people could it
be because we're the ones that actually
want to basically bribe them
we want to endlessly bribe them so that
they'll keep voting for us because
otherwise none of our policies actually
work for them and lindsey graham you're
now part of it you're part of it so this
is this is neo-racism there is no one
and this is one of the things to get to
the previous segment that i would want
bill maher to come around to there is no
one on the right in mainstream on the
right who wants anyone judged by the
color of their skin that isn't to say
that there aren't some far right races
somewhere
there are
but there is no one mainstream there is
no thought leader there is no politician
that wants people treated differently
based on the color of their skin their
gender and at this point even their
sexuality but it is a mainstream idea on
the left it is within the ethos of the
democratic party and i wish bill maher
luck fixing that because he's going
against joe biden and he's going
basically against republican light but i
would say at this point basically
democrat lindsey graham as well